[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in [music] this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. who are honored
to continue.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary [music] care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. [music] Results vary and may
not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you have options
available. We are honored to have a
founding father [music] of the science
of epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content [music] is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary
[music] care physician. The statements
in this program have
All right. Hello everybody. Welcome to
Daily with Doc. My name is Becca Dukes
and as the hostess of this program, it
is my honor and privilege to be able to
share with you information that empowers
you. Rather than taking that power away
and being dependent on a system that
just wants to look at giving something
to mask symptoms,
you can actually be empowered to look at
underlying causes and take what is
needed in order to address those
underlying causes so that those symptoms
either diminish or no longer exist. How
does that sound? Well, for me, that was
something that was kind of a pipe dream.
I thought, "Okay, something there's
something I'm missing. There's something
I'm missing. There's got to be something
better than this and better than being
pushed off to
pain management."
And that pain management had to do with
my spine. So today we are going to be
talking about spinal stenosis and all
that comes with it and how there is
actually something that you yourself can
do and our one and only Dr. Joel Wallik
is going to be sharing what that is. So
if you were invited to this program by
somebody specific, make sure that you
get back with them. They took the time
and cared enough about you to share this
program with you. If there is no one to
thank, we do have a call team that is
standing by at 8559493377.
This call team is for those who have
never spoken to anybody about anything
that is mentioned on this program. They
were not referred to this program by
anybody specific. nor have they tried
the products that are talked about on
this program. Now,
this program is being sponsored by Daily
with Doc. You're welcome to go to Daily
with Doc, sign up for our email list
where you will get notifications of when
our show is live and also how to access
our recordings. You will also be able to
see the good foods, bad foods list that
has been put together by Dr. Dr. Joel
Wallik based on his decades of
experience as a pathologist and looking
at things that were causing issues
within the body of those who actually
were affected by these poor food
choices. So, we really encourage you to
take a good look at that good foods, bad
foods list because it really does make a
difference. Now, without further ado, I
am honored to be able to present and
share with you what my mentor, the man
who I heard on the radio about eight
years ago now. It was just over eight
years ago that actually offered a
glimpse of hope for me. I knew there was
something different. I knew I was
missing something. I knew that just
being pushed off to me pain management
was not the answer and he had answers
that I thought okay
I'll try one more thing and I am so glad
that I did because that one more thing
gave me my life back. So Dr. Joel
Wallik, you are you've just you've had
this incredible life story that has
turned into a journey that has turned
into a crusade where you have empowered
people to take control of their own
health and help others do the same. Now
with a bachelor of science and uh
agriculture
>> Yep. in agriculture and dealing with
plants and soil and then got veterary
medicine where you worked your way
through veterary school as or in the
pathology lab which then because of the
paper that you wrote. Your very first
paper in your early 20s got you invited
to be part of an amazing
save the white rhino expedition saving
them from extinction which was very
successful and that just led to so many
different things including working in
the Yorks Primate Center where you found
the first nonhuman case of cystic
fibrosis. Not only found the first case
of nonhuman cystic fibrosis, which was
said to be a genetic disease. You proved
that it was not genetic. You found the
underlying cause and you were fired when
you presented this information because
it was it was against a narrative. And
there are so many narratives, Dr. Wallik
out there that you
knew that what you were on to was
correct to the point of suing the FDA
eight times and winning with the help of
your attorney Jonathan Eort.
You also you went on to teach nutrition
at a naturopathic medicine college and
then became a naturopathic physician. So
you have all of these credentials that I
think really
shouts out that you know a little bit
about what you're talking about and the
fact that I myself have benefited so
greatly and many many others that I've
been able to share your message with it
just is I think it's criminal to keep it
to myself. So that's why we've got Daily
with Doc and I have a whole amazing crew
of co-hosts who feel the same way as
many of the guests that we have. So I
just want to do a shout out and welcome
to those who are live with us in our
Zoom. Thank you for being here with us
and just be a sponge. Take notes. But he
talks fast so there's good thing that
there's the recordings. I also want to
do a shout out to our YouTube audience,
our Rumble audience, our Amazon Music
audience, our Spotify audience, the
Patreon, the Brighton,
um, all these different places that
we're now streaming, including LinkedIn,
Instagram, Twitter. It's just fantastic,
Dr. Wall, that we're able to get this
message out to so many places, and all
we have to do is one show that reaches
millions.
I think that's kind of what you wanted
to do, isn't it? You want to reach the
>> Can't thank you and your team enough for
getting this message out there. Um
because one person can't do it all. So
as we have so many so many literally
thousands of stories every month, okay?
Because we're affecting the entire world
in a positive way. And we can't thank
you and your team enough for making sure
everything's going in the right
direction. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you.
>> Well, I can't thank my team enough
either because trying to do it all on my
own um was a little bit stressful.
So, I can understand when you just were
getting started trying to get this
message out and trying to do it on your
own. You had to get others to help you
on this. So, and it continues. So, we
can continue to to share the message.
But today, Dr. So like let's talk about
spinal stenosis. I know from experience
spinal stenosis is like this the
narrowing of that canal that goes down
through the spine that is
causes pressure on the spinal cord and
cause so many different issues pain
immobility.
What causes that and what can we do Dr.
Wallik?
Okay. Well, when you have the
um things going on with spinal stenosis,
this is a very simple nutritional
deficiency disease. It's osteoporosis
of the vertebrae. It's nutritional
deficiencies
of the disc between the vertebrae. And
so the canal from the from the skull
down to the tailbone that the spinal
cord goes through and all the spinal
nerves come off at the various places
are really about 10% of the internal
volume that they should be. They've lost
90%. Because when you have osteoporosis
the the measurement outside measurements
and inside measurements the bones get
bigger but it's not normal. It's
actually abnormal tissue closing up the
tunnels which the nerves and spinal cord
go through and that's what causes the
symptoms. And um you can have symptoms
in your shoulders and your arms. You can
have symptoms in your digestive tract,
your lungs, your heart,
[clears throat] your liver. Um things
like the intestines, the kidneys. Oh,
that's a big one. Kidneys or the um
arteries and the nerves. Okay. Come from
the spinal column to the kidneys and the
kidneys can't function properly. Well,
the kidneys have to do with blood
pressure. They have to do with getting
rid of bad stuff in the urine, urinating
out bad stuff into the environment so
you don't have to have the bad stuff in
you. So, people really don't understand
the appreciation of the kidneys, okay?
When it comes to saving you, okay, and
then making your life better. When it
comes to spond spondylitis,
um it can be in the neck only. It can be
in in the um spinal cord in the should
in the thor thoracic area, in the chest
area. It could be in your lumbar area,
your lower back, or it can be in all
those places. And so it just depends on
a lot of things. how much of what you're
eating, how often you're eating the
right stuff, how often you're eating the
bad stuff. [clears throat] And so this
is why we came out with the flip chart.
The flip chart is I don't know 75 pages,
something like that. And the title,
>> yeah, the title of the flip chart is 95
say to save humanity in the world. Well,
basically we talk about these things.
The medical doctors, they knew they
could identify the problem, but they
didn't know it was causing the problem.
They thought it was a genetic thing, an
age thing. It never
came to their mind that it was a
combination of nutritional deficiencies
because they don't get taught nutrition
in those areas. And
it's one of those which I say one of
those endless processes where everything
will gradually get worse if you're not
dealing with the cause. Okay. And just
of course in the beginning people oh I
can't I love my doctor. I can't wait to
give him some kind of gift because uh I
just couldn't smile. I couldn't walk. I
couldn't talk. I couldn't do anything
because of the pain. and he gave me this
new product that's out and in six hours
all my pain that I'd had for years went
away and suddenly now I can do more. I'm
not perfect but 50% better is better
than nothing. And the pain being
painfree that was worth and so this is
where the whole idea of dealing with the
pain issues
um really got the medical system going.
Okay, our main goal here is to as
quickly as possible eliminate pain. The
patient will be happy and keep coming
back.
>> Well, that's why I got sent off to pain
management because they couldn't think
of anything else that would work, doc.
And and I appreciated them for trying. I
really did.
There was several that that tried. Oh, I
know exactly what to do. And we would
give it a good shot and you know for
months
and it and for for many people
the pain medications that they're
prescribing
you cannot take because of severe
reactions. And that was me. All of these
things that they were trying were making
me deathly sick. um including you I
blacked out once and woke up 3 days
later because of the reaction I had from
the medications. So
when I heard that there was
the possibility
of nutrition being the underlying cause,
I'm like, well, I eat good, Dr. Wallik.
I I wasn't junk food eater. I had my own
garden. I was very um
well I I wanted to be as natural as
possible
and pharmaceuticals and chemicals were
just not part of that. So whenever I
heard your message and taking nutrition
that's plant derived,
I'm like, "Okay, this is something I'm
open
to try." Even though there's a few
things I mean, especially that the
liquids there might there has to be a
preservative to keep it from molding,
right? Keep it from separating.
But
all the goodness that was in there, I'm
like, "Okay, this is so worth it." So, I
gave it a shot and
uh I'm so glad that I did, doc.
>> Yeah, you're one of the stories, you
know, in the flip chart.
Okay. So, has a great picture before and
after of you lost what 125 pounds kind
of thing.
>> No, Dr. Hollik, I've only lost 100
pounds, but I was 120 pounds overweight.
So, my journey on that weight is not
over. But
I do have to say I know some thin people
that are not healthy.
So, even having that 20 pounds that I
think is too much, at least I'm healthy.
>> Mhm.
>> And, you know, this may just be where
God says my body's the best at.
>> Yeah. You have to appreciate
um what's the difference between now and
the and the Garden of Eden thousands of
years ago. Well, thousands of years ago,
humans were using wood and coal as fuel,
putting the wood ashes and coal ashes
into their food as a spice because it
tasted good. They're getting the
minerals that way. Then they put them in
the garden as a fertilizer for their own
backyard garden. And again, they're
getting minerals when you burned the
wood and the coal and you took the wood
ashes out of the stove and the fireplace
and threw them in the garden. But they
weren't exactly the same place after
place after place, farm after farm after
farm because nutritional minerals are
not formed by plants.
Plants can make vitamins, but they can't
make minerals. And [clears throat]
plants only need three minerals and
human beings need 60. And so you can be
eating a pretty good meal and you're
growing everything yourself, but the
plants only have maybe four or five or
six minerals in them. So you're missing
54.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. You're missing quite a few.
>> Yeah. And so that's that's where I I
figured out well you know we're we're
giving all these minerals to our animals
and they don't have these disease
including all these birth defects like
cyicrosis and muscular and sediment
death syndromes and more but those are
the three that I got rid of just by
putting nutrients into various diets for
for people and I I'm the one and my team
eliminated
cystic fibrosis muscularity and STD
cinema death syndrome. You think about
that. They were all just simple
nutritional deficiencies and diseases
and after
hundreds of years of having them really
causing terrible
discomfort and just what just everything
in the human populations all over the
world.
um when we um went to
um electricity, no more wood ashes, no
more no more wood ashes, no more coal
ashes, and our source of our nutritional
minerals went away after thousands of
years. And so that's why suddenly now
hospitals
became factories.
Prior to that, medical doctors were
mostly just herbalists,
okay? Okay. And they'd tell you about
bone broth and stuff like that. And they
would go from little community to little
community. They they give a lecture at
the church and then they go to people's
houses and have dinner with them and
talk about what herb to use for this
that and the other. That went on for
thousands of years. Then suddenly now
when all our source of our minerals went
away and they had these drugs now
because the pharmaceutical industry that
could relieve pain suddenly now there's
lines lining up for the hospitals get
those drugs.
>> Well there's so many different poor
health conditions that were popping up.
I know you had linked what was it over
600 different symptoms that have been
directly associated with nutritional
deficiencies. Over 600
>> Yeah. 600 symptoms and diseases. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And many of those are said to be
genetic, Dr. Wallik.
>> None.
>> So if it's a simple nutritional
deficiency, how can it be genetic?
>> Yeah. Well, when the doctors didn't
know, they never wanted to say, "I don't
know." So, doctors said it was a genetic
thing. It's your fault. You know, your
family passed that on to you.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And again, it's one of those
things where um and and
uh the whole idea, one of my favorites
is, of course, the metabolic
um
Okay.
>> syndrome.
>> Metabolic syndrome.
>> Yeah. have the metabolic syndrome and in
1945 it was diagnosed and said to be
genetic 1945
and
I figured out what caused it just a
couple years ago
and essentially you don't hear about
um metabolic syndrome much anymore but
it's
>> well actually I'm apologize for stopping
you there now Dr.
Now metabolic syndrome is bigger than
ever because they have not heard your
message.
So they're going to hear it and that's
actually your next book that we're
working on is about the metabolic
syndrome. It's going to be a fairly
short read but very impactful.
So I'm glad that you had the drive to
put that together. used to be about the
size of a soul in your head, which is
about the brain and the spinal cord and
the cranial nerves. And this one, okay,
um, metabolic syndrome
was
put together and diagnosed in 1945 by a
bunch of doctors
right after the Second World War. Of
course, everybody was suffering from
nutritional deficiencies because the
farms were shutting down. They're
sending the farmers out to go fight the
war and all that kind of stuff. And so
um these nutritional deficiencies caught
up with us 1945
and the um uh
the the whole idea of the metabolic
syndrome. Okay
has a core picture. Okay. abdominal
obesity, diabetes, high blood pressure,
kidney disease,
um liver disease,
and many more, but those are the main
ones. And they said, "This is the
syndrome. You got all these things going
on here, and you got this gene, and you
we had to do some surgeries here. We got
to give you these drugs that relieve
pain and inflammation
to the fact that all of these things
including abdominal obesity,
okay, and
the um diabetes and high blood pressure
and
um
heart issues and stomach issues and
kidney issues and um liver issues are
all nutritional deficiencies.
So, as soon as we started treating all
these folks, okay, with the metabolic
syndrome,
I mean, we're getting rid of these
things. One of my favorites is a gal,
this is on page 27 of the flip chart,
okay? She had Parkinson's disease, okay,
which is as, you know, said to be one of
those terrible genetic things. and
Parkinson disease. No, Parkinson disease
is one of those things where um her name
is Maline O. And she was going to her
doctor
specialist in Parkinson disease two or
three times a year for 11 years getting
worse. And he's telling her, "Okay, the
end is coming. You're getting worse. You
know, our make you feel good approach
isn't working much anymore. So, you
know, kind of get rid of all your um
things that you want to get rid of. Talk
to your family. You know, we're getting
close. You might have six months or a
year left. And we got her on our
program. And in two and a half months,
she was cured. And the doctor said,
"This can't be right. So, come back
tomorrow. We'll do another examination."
It was perfect. She was perfect. And on
page 27 of the flip chart on the right
hand half of that page, okay, she tells
her story,
okay, and her salient messages in
highlighted in yellow and then on the
left hand side of the page there's a
mixture of patient and doctor letters.
Okay? Because
even yet today um doctors can't believe
that the metabolic syndrome is something
that can be prevented reversed that
Parkinson's disease is not a genetic
thing an age thing but it it doubled
Parkinson disease
for many
dozens of years hundreds of years
Parkinson disease occurred at the rate
of 60,000 new cases each year in America
60,000 new cases teacher in America.
This last year was 90,000. It went up
50%.
Because doctors had shut off the foods
that contain the good stuff in it and
just gave pain relievers.
>> Yeah, it does seem to be quite a shame,
Dr. Wallick. That's for sure. And that's
why our message needs to be heard even
more so. Um, so folks, if you're
watching us on this on the replay or out
on any of the different media platforms
and you're able to share, please share.
Please share. You have people within
your circle that this can benefit that
they've never heard the message of hope
that Dr. Wallik has brought to us today
and every week as we are bringing Daily
with Doc to you. Starting next week, it
will be Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
and Friday. So, I'm super excited to
bring Dr. Wallik and some of the other
doctors that have found the value in his
message that they have been able to
implement within their own practices and
helping their clients even more, not be
dependent on pharmaceuticals, but
actually looking at the nutrition side
that is needed to address underlying
causes. So, Dr. get back to spinal
stenosis if you would please because we
have a young man. He's 37 years old.
He's 6'3,
175 pounds. So, he's tall and thin and
way too young to be going through the
spinal stenosis that he is experiencing.
Um, and he's got C7
uh with a bulging disc between six and
seven. He has severe nerve pain.
um which I can relate to. But Dr.
Wallik, what would you recommend for
somebody who has symptoms that we've
been talking about that have to do with
the spinal stenosis, which is a medical
term, which is basically the narrowing
of the of the canal be along the spinal
cord that's squeezing the spinal cord
and the nerves. What would you recommend
as being a nutritional solution for
that?
>> Okay. Well, um, let's see. He weighs 173
pounds.
>> 175 pounds at 6 foot three.
>> Okay. 6 foot three. Okay. So, he's get
rid of all the bad foods. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils, no
glutens, no wheat, no bron oats, no
sugar, no carbonated drinks. Even the
diet ones got to go. [clears throat] And
then at 175 lbs, I want him to have two
healthy brain and heart packs a per
month, the full do twice a day. Then I
want them to have nine a day of our
glucco gel capsules. This takes a place
of the old um bone broth. Okay, the
glucagel capsules. Three at breakfast,
three at lunch, dinner time. I take
three twice a day. I only weigh 142.
Okay.
And [clears throat]
uh that's going to help him regrow the
disc in between the vertebrae also the
um cartilage in his knees and hips and
shoulders because it's not only
happening in his vertebrae. It's
happening all over the place. Okay. And
uh let's see here. Then also our vitamin
D3 to have three a day. One at
breakfast, one at lunch, one at dinner
time of our vitamin D3. Okay. And that's
going to help him absorb the minerals
properly and so forth. And I also want
him to instead of drinking soft drinks,
even the diet ones got to go because
they're carbonated. I want them to for
energy, I want him to
which is a energy drink we made for our
athletes. Okay. And I like the um
powder. Okay.
So, because it doesn't have the the
carbonation in it. Okay. And
then let's see here. I think
um
Oh, um for pain relief in the area that
he's got the stenosis, any place else
he's got pain, whether it's his neck or
his knees or whatever. And then the area
of stenosis is our CM cream. Go ahead
and put you know, um, couple of
teaspoons on that area right on the spot
and around it and so forth. And you
could do that. You'll get relief of pain
for about 3 to five hours depending on
how deep and and how how
they say how big the pain zone is. But,
uh, it's okay to use two three times a
day. And
I like people to use it when they wake
up in the morning in the middle of the
day sometimes to peak at which they're
feeling problems. And then maybe uh a
half hour before bedtime. That way they
get to sleep without having restless
sleep because of so much pain. Okay? So
a minimum of three times a day. You
could do it five times a day. It doesn't
have anything bad in it. There's there's
nothing bad in the CM cream. So, um,
also,
>> let me throw one more thing in there to
help the brain and the spinal cord and
the spinal nerves and the cranial nerves
because this doesn't happen in just one
little location. One little location. C7
could be the worst place, but it's
happening all over, right? And so, um,
it also needs the I26,
which rebuilds the white matter of the
brain and spinal cord.
Okay. And that will definitely help um
with uh brain and spinal cord function.
>> How about the MSM Ultra, Dr. Wallik?
>> Yeah. Well, I use it, too. You know, if
you come and look at my kitchen table, I
have the MSM. I have the MSM Ultra. I
take three of those twice a day. I take
a lot of stuff. I can say I weigh 142
lbs. I probably take enough for a 400 lb
man. Okay. Eight 800 lb, Dr.
>> I counted.
>> Okay. Okay. So, that's that's that's
more than um jelly roll.
>> Yes, it is actually. I I think he's only
about four. So, or between three and
four. So, yeah. Well, Dr. all um I and I
one thing that I want to add that that I
was able to do is because essential oils
have some amazing properties in helping
to to relieve pain as well. And I would
add just a couple drops of that trauma
essential oil to the CM cream. And when
I say a couple drops, I'm thinking four
max to a 2 ounce container. Maybe five
if you're a tough guy. Okay? But for for
those of us that are uh fair,
it's some pretty powerful stuff.
So folks, I I'm hoping that you
understand that there's a lot that you
yourself can do to help yourself
when it comes to all of these different
medical conditions. And Dr. Wallik, we
had mentioned briefly about things not
being genetic. And one of the books that
really gave me hope when it came to my
health and the things that were going on
is your book epigenetics. Um, which is
the death of the genetic theory of
disease transmission. because many of
those things that I had been diagnosed
with and I actually didn't hear about
metabolic syndrome until
uh 1996
95 or 96 um is when I heard the first
time for the first time metabolic
syndrome and many of the things that
they had told me that I had going on
with me were genetic and I was just
going to have to live with it.
But that book
gave me hope in thinking, okay, maybe I
don't have to live with those things.
That if if I follow Dr. Wallik's
recommendations
that I can find my way out of this
downhill spiral of poor health and it
worked.
So, I encourage everybody to go to
drjwallik.com
and get the book epigenetics. That's
also where you can find the flip chart
and all of his other 24 different
publications books that he has written
over his lifetime. You can get them at
drjwallik.com.
Now, the reason why I really promote,
you know, his books is because he does
not get paid for the sales of the
product that he's recommending. He is
the founder of the company, Young.
He has handed that over to his son and
daughter-in-law who now run the company.
And he did that because he did not want
to be accused of only promoting products
because he makes a dime off of them or
makes a buck off of them. He has turned
that over to them and he actually is
supported by his book sales. And this
the valuable information within those
books were truly it's saving lives and I
can attest to that because I'm one of
them. So thank you so much Dr. Wallik
for for all that you've done and your
continued dedication
to humanity.
>> Well, thank you for that. And of course,
you have jumped in with both feet and
you're participating because we have a
new book coming out by the end of June.
Is that correct? By the end of June or
the end of May?
>> End of May.
>> End of May. Just a month away from now.
This new book should be out. Okay. And
it's called The Metabolic Syndrome.
metabolic syndrome.
>> I'm thinking we need to have some type
of catchy catchy
title afterwards. Still working on that.
>> Okay.
>> So, yes, that will be available by the
end of May. Um, and you know, Dr. Well,
one more thing that I that I want to
mention that I think is truly a
testament to your dedication of getting
this information out to people is you
actually
paid millions of dollars out of your own
pocket
to sue the FDA. That wasn't something
that Jonathan Nemore did pro bono.
that you sold your farm, your mother
sold her farm to help fund that push to
get the nutrients into things like baby
formula, prenatal vitamins to help end
some and the folic acid. Yeah. I mean
>> to get rid of to get rid of cyicosis,
muscular and ced syndrome.
>> By getting Yeah. By getting those
nutrients into baby fountains, we
eliminated those terrible three
diseases.
>> Yeah.
>> In human babies.
>> And it was something so simple. So
folks, health is simple.
It may not be easy because of what we're
programmed to do by media or family
tradition, but it's actually simple. And
we invite you to feel the difference in
what it is that nutrition can do within
the body because our products are not
meant to treat, diagnose, cure any
diseases. But it's those
that synergistic blend of the nutrients
that have been proven time and time
again. You can go to pubmed.gov, go look
up specific nutrients and find that they
are truly linked to the when the
deficiency is there to poor health
conditions. So Dr. Wall put together
this amazing team that formulated
these products that synergistically
worked together in a form that's
absorbable because there are studies
where they take over-the-counter
multivitamins. you're only getting
between eight and 26% absorption. But
then when you they did the same testing
on the products and formulas that Dr.
Wallik's team put together, you're
getting over 90% absorption.
And that's powerful.
You're not just paying it out, right,
Doc?
>> That's right. Yeah. The whole idea
just like, you know, people, they don't
just wash their car once a week. They
make sure they're looking at that um
you know they're they're looking at all
the different gauges, okay,
on the um screen and in front of their
steering wheel, okay? And they're seeing
um all the different pressures and
temperatures and all kind of stuff. And
so they check the oil and they check the
antifreeze and they check the brake
fluid and they check the fluid for the
um transmission.
um they check the gasoline, use high
quality gasoline and so forth. We don't
have a
a flip chart in front of us so that as
you're walking down the street, you can
see what's going on with all of your
nutrients and all the various functions
of your body.
But right,
>> basically our meters are pain
pain, dizziness, uh discomfort, maybe
discomfort is is a better word for it,
whether it be through where anywhere
throughout the body. So folks, don't
ignore those signs, those warning lights
like Dr. Wallik was mentioning about
having all the different gauges. Don't
ignore those.
Get back with the person that shared
this program with you and thank them.
Tell them what you learned most about
what you have heard so far. Dr. W, we
have comments that are coming in. Uh
we've got Joe who's out there who has
said he thinks that your products are
actually working. He's been on them for
just a little bit now and is feeling
much much better. Um, we have a a
question that is coming in from an here
in the Zoom with us and she had just
received a bottle of the ultimate
niacin. Now, when you say ultimate
nasin, folks, we're not talking about
single individual nutrient. Okay? Dr.
Wellik's team has formulated with these
different nutrients that actually work
together to to support the body
even better.
Now with the nascin, she says, "I am
taking it one per day. Seems to be going
really well. At 130 pounds, she's
wondering if she should up it to two per
day."
Well, if she wants to, she can try. It
won't be dangerous, but she might get
hot flashes and that kind of stuff. When
you take high doses of nasin, you get
hot flashes. Okay? So if you're getting
some benefit and you're not getting high
flashes, that's a good place to be with
nasin. I only take one of those a day
and I take them in the morning as
opposed to taking him in the evening
with evening nutrients because I don't
want to, you know, risk getting up in
the middle of the night with hot
flashes.
>> No. Well, and it's kind I'm maybe I'm an
exception. Maybe I shouldn't, but you
know, I take one and I get a little bit
of that flush, but I take two and I
don't feel it at all. So, it may just be
me. But, Dr. Waller, share with us a
little bit what the ultimate niacin is
designed to help with in addition to the
90 essential nutrients. Now, you have to
have the foundation, folks. That
foundation is what feeds the body. And
then the secret sauce like the ultimate
niain would be for somebody who what
wants to include blood flow
>> well want to wants to make proper blood
flow but also nasin's involved in
transmission of nerve impulses. It has
to do with the brain and the spinal cord
talking to each other. Okay. And so
[clears throat]
um nasin deficiency is something that
everybody should be being concerned
about and have their kids and grandkids
and nieces and nephews and brothers and
sisters and spouses. Everybody should be
having at least one of those uh nasin
pluses. Okay. Um and again I would take
them in the morning so that you're not
risking getting a flush at night or
something like that. And you say I'm not
going to take it anymore. I got up in
the middle of the night with this hot
flash. Okay. And so you want to take it
um in the morning and so that's when I
take mine and
it's one of those things where you know
it does its job. It's one of the 90
essential nutrients. It's one of the B
vitamins nascin and um it has a function
and so it's an essential nutrient. It's
not something well you can do without.
You have to have it.
>> All right.
Thank you so much for that. And I want
to point out Joe out on YouTube says
that my spine is healing gradually. Pain
is way down. I was in a headon car crash
and my midspine was always not right and
had herniated discs. And that that's I
want to bring this up because where we
talk about the nutritional deficiencies
and all of the different symptoms that
nutritional deficiencies
can cause, the nutrition can also be a
solution to injury and supporting the
body so that the it can in fact overcome
the injuries that were caused by things
like car accidents. I myself five
herniated discs from a car accident.
It stunk. It hurt really bad. And the
nutrition helped with that as well.
>> Well, the nutrition is required to
repair the disc and the vertebrae and
and the spinal cord uh and so forth. And
so, you know, doctors say, "Oh, don't
waste your money on those vitamins.
They're just eat everything you need."
That's absolutely positively not true.
You cannot get everything you need
because nutritional minerals for
instance plants only need three when you
need 60. Nutritional minerals do not
occur in a uniform blank around the
crust of the earth. They are in veins
like gold and silver. Does gold and
silver occur uniformly all over the
world? No. People spent a lot of their
time and their life and their money
searching digging holes in mountains and
digging holes in valleys looking for
those veins of gold and silver. Some
people spent their lifetime looking and
never found it. Some people got lucky
and they hit it. You know, I've been
looking for 10 years and finally found
it. Okay? And so, it's one of those
things where um when you're taking these
nutrients, you're saving a lot of time
because you're taking what you know you
need and you can there are certain
things you take to increase the healing
efficiency and healing rate.
And if you didn't know it before this
show, you know it now, folks. You need
90 essential nutrients daily. That's 60
minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 amino acids,
and at least two essential fatty acids
daily in order to feed the body so that
the body cannot
survive
each and every day. Because sometimes
that's what people feel like. I'm I'm
just surviving. But thrive, you have it
within you. When the body is given the
right combination of nutrients, you have
the ability to thrive.
Even if you have previous nutritional
deficiency cause symptoms, even if
you've been through accidents. Now, we
cannot guarantee 100% healing. That's
that's totally up to the good Lord.
nutrition, what you're putting in your
diet, which I want to go back to the
good foods, bad foods list on daily with
doc. You can find that in the menu. And
because of what Dr. Wallik is holding
up, epigenetics, the death of the
>> genetic Yeah.
>> um theory of transmission,
there's a lot that we ourselves can do.
So doc's also holding up let's play
doctor which goes through so many
different poor health conditions Dr.
Wallik and gives recommendations on what
to do and that was actually written kind
of before longevity came about.
>> That's correct.
>> They made it simple in putting these
formulas together that included the
recommendations that Dr. Wallik made me
in the book and also dead doctors don't
lie with over 400,000 copies uh
distributed throughout the world
greatest
>> how many million of the CD
>> the greatest lecturer I was going there
>> the greatest medical health lecture has
over 40 million
copies that have been um purchased and
distributed throughout and That number I
think Dr. Wallik is actually a little
bit outdated because the last edition on
that book was just a few years ago. So
we have a goal to make sure people hear
the message and giving
them power
empowering you empowering others. So
please help us help us spread that
message. Now Dr. Wik, we do have a
couple hands up now. Let's first go to
Jane.
So Jane, go ahead and unmute yourself.
Here I am. Uh I went to the
>> I I went to the heart doctor yesterday
and um my [clears throat] blood pressure
was quite amazing. It was actually too
low for me, but it was 116 over 70. But
>> that's beautiful.
>> Exactly. And I'm taking the Ultimate
Daily Classic. I'm taking six of those a
day. Problem is when I take it's
constant when I do the I think it's an
EKG test.
[clears throat] The um my part is
irregular. So she's immediately again
I'm not taking it recommended Eloquis a
blood thinner.
I wonder what your thoughts are about
taking a blood thinner.
>> Well, how much do you weigh?
>> Uh 109.
>> Okay. Um you need to get rid of all the
bad foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat, no
bar ran oats, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbon drinks. That one's got to go. And
then [clears throat] at um let's see
here.
U weigha 109 you said.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm taking a lot of your other
things too, but but I'm taking
specifically the Ultimate Daily Classic
for that.
>> Daily Classic. Yeah. Ultimate Daily
Placid is for uh high pressure and and
obstructed arteries from plaque in the
arteries. And so um you know, you could
take two or three twice a day. Okay. The
ultimate daily classic. guy weigh 142
and I take um uh three twice a day the
ultimate daily classic.
Okay. And um these are the sort of
things you can do and get things under
control and you get rid of the bad
foods. So you're coming at these
problems from two different directions.
You need the things that make things
work and you need to avoid the stuff
that interferes with proper function.
Okay? And so by doing those two things
um you will see benefit. But um people
would be so grateful to have a blood
pressure 116 over 70. you know, they're
140 over over 100 and something and
they're right on that margin of really
in danger having heart attacks and all
that kind of stuff. And so, no, you're
in good shape. Just keep doing what
you're doing, but stay away from the bad
bad stuff. Don't ever think, well, I can
cheat a little bit here. Don't do that.
>> So, you don't think I need the blood
thinner?
>> No. Well, if I can if I can just point
out something that she mentioned and the
reason why they're putting her on the
blood thinner is because of an irregular
heartbeat.
>> Okay. Well, irregular heartbeat that
could be due to a lot of things. Okay.
Could be due to osteoposis of the skull
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve.
Okay. Uh which controls [clears throat]
rate and rhythm of the heart.
Okay. And so that's a possibility. Uh do
you have any ringing in your ears? Any
tonitis?
>> I I still have a slight not major but
yes it never stops.
>> Yeah, you have osteoporosis of the skull
that's squeezing those nerves. That's
what's making your heart beat
irregularly. And so you need to take our
vitamin D3. Take three of those a day.
Take one with each meal or vitamin D3.
Okay. And then also you need to uh take
our I26. Go ahead and take two or three
of those tubles twice a day. I26 is
going to help rebuild the myelin, the
white matter of the brain, spinal cord,
and the white matter of the covering of
the the nerves, including the ones that
control the heart. And [clears throat]
by taking all these nutrients for all
these different systems
um that's going to make you know your
heart can beat regularly and um and not
have tacky cardia and all that kind of
stuff. You'll know things are happening
good when that tenitis when that ring in
the ears starts getting less and less
and less and less. Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you, Jane. And you're
looking vibrant, my dear. Thanks for
help being on with us today.
Let's go over to the next hand that is
up Dr. Wallik and we have Bill. Bill, go
ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Okay.
Can you hear me? Okay.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. Thank you, Dr. Wall. I've been
using the I26 TMR collagen and the brain
and body pack and I've had for over a
dozen years uh the essential tremors
familial tremors and neurologist last
week and I took it for four days u
premodone and it just didn't threw me
for a loop. So I've stopped that.
Um, what else would you recommend? I26,
TMR, calgen brain body pack at the
moment.
>> Yeah. And
>> 142.
>> Yeah, the i26 is really good for this
kind of stuff.
>> How much you weigh?
>> 142.
>> 142. Yes. Yeah. I'd go you're about my
weight and so I would go with three of
the chewables.
Okay. Um, two, three times a day. Okay,
that's going to help enormously.
>> How about Synaptive, Dr. Wallik?
>> Okay, that's a good that's a good one,
too. Synaptive. I take two of those
twice a day.
>> And what's the purpose of the synaptive,
doc?
>> That's so your brain cells can talk to
each other. That's so your spinal cord
cells can talk to each other. That's so
your heart cells can talk to each other.
Synapse is a space between
two nerves and if they don't have all
the right stuff they can't send the
message from over the gap and so
synaptive gives your body the raw
materials it needs to be able to fill
that gap
>> and have is that to break through the
myelin barrier?
>> No, it doesn't have to break through the
milein barrier. It's absorbed.
>> Understood.
>> The myin that's another story. Okay, you
got two or three or four possibilities
there. So the the synaptive is good.
That's for one thing. That's for the
nerves talking to each other. And then I
26 is for the white matter of the brain
and spinal cord um actually
um
what should I say surviving being
crushed by the skull also providing
shelter from outside forces.
uh also carrying the message from one
area of your brain and spinal cord to
another area of your brain and spinal
cord. So the I26 was a real breakthrough
and uh it it covered an area which for
years people didn't quite know how to um
help the brain spinal cord talk to its
different zones. I mean, you know, you
have somebody who's six foot tall and
how do you get the brains and the in and
the upper spinal cord in the first part
of the neck
to your
um big nerves is that split off from the
spinal cord down in your pelvis. Okay.
And so this is why we came up with that.
>> All right.
Thank you so much. Thank you, Bill, for
coming on and giving us that learning
moment as well. We appreciate that.
Let's go over to Coach AJ, Dr. Wallik.
So,
AJ, what questions are you bringing to
the table today?
>> Hey, Dr. Wallik, how's it going?
>> Okay, sir. What's going on?
>> You know, uh, we have a gentleman named
Darwin who is 61 and 240 pounds. And he
says, Dr. Wallik, what is the best
treatment for my diabetes and or how can
I truly get rid of it, doc?
>> Okay. Diabetes is a simple nutritional
deficiency disease. You weigh 240
pounds. That's what he weighs.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. He's getting rid of all the bad
foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat,
butter, rat oats, no um buckwheat, no
sugar, no carbonated drinks. The diet
one's got to go. At 240 pounds, I'd have
him take two healthy brain and heart
packs per month, full twice a day. And
with type two diabetes, I'd have him
take three of the sweeties at breakfast,
three at lunch, and three at dinner
time. And don't just cold turkey stop
taking your medication. But as the blood
sugar begins to drop, you can slowly
reduce prescription medication.
And you know, we take people that are
diagnosed with really serious type 2
diabetes for 25 years and in two to four
weeks they're not a diabetic anymore
because it's very simple nutritional
deficiency disease. And you can wash
your car
10 times a day. Is that going to fix a
flat tire? No.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. So just the two
healthy brain and heart packs and and
three sweeties three times a day. And
you think he's would be better in
getting off the bad foods. Of course.
>> That's right. And he's going to save a
lot of money by getting off the bad
foods. How tall is this guy?
>> 61.
>> Okay. 61. Okay. So he's somewhere around
35 to 40 pounds overweight. Okay. And
he's going to lose some weight there.
Okay. He's going to lose some weight and
and he should, you know, be good to get
down to like 210, 205, 210, something
like that. Okay.
>> Thank you, Doc. Did you hear about that
newest national treasure?
>> No. What?
>> It's you.
>> Oh, really?
>> Thank you, Doc.
>> Thank you, sir.
>> All right. Thank you, AJ. And yes, Dr.
Wallick, you definitely are a treasure.
Yeah. Well, that's actually what the the
um uh the government, you know, in in
the museums.
>> Well, yeah. The original copy of this
big bad boy
right here, Diseases of Exotic Animals,
Medical and Surgical Management. The
original is in the Smithsonian Museum as
a national treasure. And look, hey,
there's your name, Doc.
>> Would you look at that?
>> That's two people. I think you're the
only one that's still living. So
>> that's fantastic.
So we have a few more minutes. Doc, can
we take two more questions?
>> Okay, sure. Why not?
>> All right. So K here in the Zoom room,
go ahead and
What's your question for Dr. Wally
today?
Hello.
Hi.
>> Hello.
>> Hi, I'm Key. Um, and
>> so I actually use my phone and this at
the same time because I can copy off of
my phone faster than I can my computer.
I have two real serious situations. It's
a husband and wife couple. Um, the
female is a type 1 diabetic. She was 55,
5'4,
125 pounds. and she they told her that
she was a type 1 diabetic at the age of
five when she got her childhood
vaccines. As a child, she said she used
to steal sugar and eat the sugar to
sustain her and steal um the fruit juice
from school. Um she does take um 15 to
20 volumes of whatever her long um
synthetic insulin is. She um got very
very sick um had endometriosis and had a
hyerectomy left with one ovary and she
got very sick after she took two of the
Fiser vaccines and she hasn't been able
to get control of her sugar since then.
>> Okay.
>> Um
>> let's stop there. You say she weighs 125
pounds.
>> Yes. Okay.
>> Does she have any She was diagnosed at
age five with type 1 diabetes.
>> Correct. Okay. Well, uh, she needs to
get rid of all the bad foods. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils, no
glutens, no wheat, no rhinos, no
buckwheat, no sugar, no carbon drinks.
Even the diet ones got to go. I have her
take one healthy brain and heart pack a
month. One healthy branded heart pack a
month. I have do everything twice a day.
I want to have
uh start her out with uh two of our
sweeties at breakfast, lunch, and
dinner. So, that's six a day. The
sweeties. Okay. do not stop her other
medication for her diabetes, but as her
blood sugar begins to go down a little
bit, she can reduce her prescription
medication a little bit. Don't just cold
turkey off the whole thing. Just reduce
it by a little bit based on the amount
of the drop in sugar. Okay? But she
needs to be eating high quality food.
And here again, it wouldn't hurt for her
have the I26. she go ahead and have two
or three of those chewables uh twice a
day. Okay, that's gonna help her white
matter of her brain and spinal cord.
Okay, so all that equipment works and
um
let's go there for that one. And you
know uh I see people who've been really
brittle diabetics of all kinds um for 25
years and in just two to four weeks are
not a diabetic anymore. But she will
have to stay on the
um she have to stay on the um what
>> the sweeties.
>> Yeah, the sweeties. She had to stay on
the sweeties forever along with the 90s
essential nutrients forever. Can't ever
quit that.
>> Okay. The other side effect that she has
is she has some depression and they have
her on like three different um
anti-depressants, SSIs. Um, and then
they also have her on a sleep thing.
>> Okay. Well, that's where the I26 will
help get rid of that.
>> All right. The other individual is her
spouse and um he's 64, 5'9,
153 pounds. He actually was diagnosed
with non um non-hodkins lymphoma. So, he
has had um chemo and a radiation. They
told him he's in um stage two of kidney
disease. He also has a melanoma that was
removed from his head and had a skin
graft and then he has something that's
on pre-treatment on his face. He does
have ringing in the ears. Um he does
have knee pain and so and total body
pain is basically what he says. He is
on, are you ready? 13 different
medications
and just two vitamins.
[laughter]
>> It's a mess.
>> Sounds like it. Okay. Again, get rid of
all the bad stuff. This will help in the
household since there's two people
having to get rid of all the bad stuff.
No fried foods, no processed meats, no
oils, no gluten, no wheat, r oats, no
buckweed, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. The diet one's got to go. 153
pounds. He needs two healthy brain heart
packs per month. photo twice a day
because of the kidney issues. Needs um
two bottles a month of the ultimate
daily classic tablets. Take three twice
a day. Would hurt to take three three
times a day. Okay. Um and of course need
the vitamin D3. Take three of those
twice twice a day of our vitamin D3.
Okay. That's going to help rebuild the
skull so that we stop that ringing in
the ears and okay that'll cause
problems. When you have tonitis ring in
the ears, okay, that's that's the um
eighth cranial nerve being squeezed,
okay, by the skull. When you have
osteoporosis of the skull, the kidney
issues, that's the ultimate daily
classic tablets. Three of those start
out twice a day, okay? And the immune
system. Okay. Again, wouldn't hurt to
take some extra vitamin, excuse me,
extra of the um um Oh, let's see here.
Let's go with
the
What mineral do you like for your immune
system?
>> Well, Dr. Well, for the immune system,
the I26 is great for the immune system.
says that that helps to get the the
digest the flora within the digestive
system, right? So that you get that
absorption which then supports the
immune system.
>> Um
>> what about the one that doctors think is
poisonous, but it's one of most
important
minerals.
>> Well, there is a new report that says
vitamin D3.
>> Yeah. Well, I said vitamin D.
>> You're thinking
>> nope. Salt.
>> No.
Selenium salt. Selenium. There you go.
Selenium.
Selenium. 153 pounds. Needs to take
about I go ahead with six selenium a
day. Two two and two. Uh I take three
twice a day and with 142
>> and that's the ultimate selenium which
is not just selenium.
>> That's correct. It has all the co-actors
necessary for it to work perfectly.
Okay, great. Perfect. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you, Keely, for coming on with
those great questions.
>> Bless you. I love you guys.
>> Bless you.
>> So, all right, Dr. Wallik, um, we are
off to the top of the hour. Do you have
time for a couple more?
>> Uh, let's go over one more.
>> Okay. Uh, Barbara has a client that has
lympadeema.
In general, for a 100 pound person, Dr.
Wallik, what would you recommend for
lympadeema?
>> Okay, 100 pound person, get rid of all
the bad stuff, which we've said many
times here. Also need to take one
healthy brain and heart pack.
Um, take a half of dose twice a day. And
then I would also take the um
let's see here. Um I I would go with the
ultimate
I was excuse me ultimate yeah ultimate
daily classic tablets. Go ahead and take
three of those. Start out with three
twice a day. Okay. That's going to help
circulation even where there's blocked
arteries, but it's going to make the
kidneys happy. Okay. The kidneys are
what's get rid of excess fluid, poisons
in the urine. Your kidneys, we have to
make them happy. Also, the slee will
help the liver do its job. It does 50
different things, including support the
immune system. Okay.
>> And the ultimate selenium is included in
the healthy body, brain, and heart pack,
folks.
>> That's correct.
>> All right. And Dr. While in our good
herbs line, there is a product called
lymphatic support which helps with that
and
I have seen some great results in
clients that have lympadeema using that
product as well.
>> Okay, good. Well, thanks for sharing
that.
>> Awesome. So, I think this is a really
important one. We'll close this on Dr.
Wallik.
So Steve is 44 years old, 175 pounds. He
has a damaged heart. Um half of the
heart, the left side of the heart is not
working due to scar tissue. Is there any
way to remove the scar tissue and regain
function?
>> Well, the left side of the heart is very
important because that pumps out all the
blood the whole body, right?
>> Yeah.
>> It weighs 144 pounds. Get rid of all the
bad foods. 175. 175. He's 44 in age.
>> Okay. 175. Okay. And then
want to get rid of all the bad foods.
Two healthy brain and heart packs per
month. Take a full dose of everything
twice a day. And then we have the procia
FX. Take two or three of those twice a
day. Procardia FX. I take three of those
twice a day also. Okay. Um
then also I like the ultimate daily
plastic tablets, okay? Because it gets
blood flowing through blocked arteries
including the coronary arteries in the
heart. Okay? [clears throat]
And so the ultimate daily classic, I'd
go with three of those twice a day
minimum. And after a week or two, week
or 10 days, move it up to three three
times a day. Okay?
And
the heart has an enormous capacity to
recover.
Okay? It has an enormous capacity for
work. And you have one little blood
vessel, one little coronary artery in
the heart blocked and it'll shut the
whole heart down. And so this is why we
came up with actually the ultimate daily
classic tablets.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that,
Dr. Wallik. Um folks, a lot of
information shared in this program. I
think it was a great day, Dr. Wallik, of
going over and covering so many
different poor health conditions that
people are having to deal with, suffer
with and there are solutions.
>> Yes.
We've been doing this for 75 years,
Rebecca. For 75 years, we have seen
thousands. No, I take that back. We have
seen tens of thousands of improvements
and reversals and cures
humans of all ages. Now, that's not even
including the animals that use these
products also.
>> Well, I'm going to bump that to like
hundreds of thousands because I know
Youngevity in itself has more than a
million clients, more than a million
customers um on a monthly basis. So,
lots of people Dr. while like have drank
the Kool-Aid and don't want to give it
up because they feel the results and I'm
one of them. So, thank you doc for being
here with us and I know we're a little
over time. We appreciate you all your
knowledge and if I could just get my
co-hosts on with me that would be
greatly appreciated. Doc, we'll see you
tomorrow.
>> Okay. Save a place for me.
>> I'll save a I'll save a place for you.
Until next time.
>> Bye bye.
>> All right, we got to let him get on to
his next show, but I just want to do a
super huge huge heartfelt thank you to
my co-hosts because if it wasn't for
them, I would not be able to do this
show. They um help make sure that
everything is rolling smoothly out on
the different platforms here in the Zoom
room, helping to answer questions on the
different platforms, bringing them to
me. So, if if I missed your question, I
apologize. We only have an hour and we
went over. Um, so make sure that you
send in your questions to questions
dailywithdoc.com
and we'll make sure that we get answers
to your questions. Again, that's
questions at dailywithdoc.com.
Now, here on our our we have a full I
think we have a full co-host team today.
So, we have Sherry who's helping to let
people in. She's also part of the tech
side and making sure that the stream
gets set up and runs smoothly. Thank
you, Sherry. We have Phyllis. Phyllis
has been one of the longest standing
distributors within Young Jevity, uh,
even prior to Youngevity, I believe. Um,
and making sure Dr. Wallik's message got
on the radio, her and her husband Andy.
So, we are very honored to have them as
part of our crew as well. We have Albert
from way down south in South America
making sure that people are able to get
into the Zoom room and uh keeping an eye
on those cameras. So folks, we just want
to make sure that you realize that if
your camera's on, whatever you do is
going to be seen. So please make sure
that you are fully dressed. We would
appreciate that. We have Marilyn who if
you are in the Zoom with us live and you
have that chat open you will see and
then Phyllis does this as well you will
see the what Dr. Wallik is recommending
repeated in black and white so that you
can take a screenshot or um
picture of what Dr. Wallik is
recommending so that you can take it to
your coach and say hey this is what Dr.
Wallik recommended either from me or
someone that has issues like mine. This
is what I need. So, we welcome you to
join us here live in the Zoom room at
dailywithdoc.com
on the days that we have our live show
so that you can benefit from that chat.
As well, we have Ruth Ellen who is our
executive production manager who helps
keep us all organized and on task. So,
thank you so much, Ruth Ellen. She's
also part of the tech crew and making
sure that we get the uh streams going
out and everything. Um, I mentioned
Albert. We have AJ who is very
instrumental in making getting us on all
these different platforms including
Apple TV, Roku TV, Fire TV. Um, just
beyond what I ever dreamed. So, thank
you AJ for for helping make this happen.
And we have Coach Rod who is out on the
different platforms and encouraging
people to just keep going and getting
questions answered and helping with that
as well. So, thank you so much, Rod. You
know, I couldn't do this without these
people. These people are my chosen
family.
And folks, there are times where we may
feel disconnected from our own family.
They may not be on the same page with
us, but if you know that there is
something to nutrition and getting it in
your body and you felt the difference
and you want to be part of a family that
then helps to support and encourage and
helps you have that motivation to share.
We invite you to be part of the Young
family. get back with a person that
shared this program with you. If you
have nobody that you have uh spoken with
and you're not part of the family or
haven't even tried the products and you
want to
give us a call at 8559493377
and we'll help you get connected
so you can use skills that you have to
be part of this family and
just
together and we can heal the world. No,
I can't say that word. We can make the
world a better place because when our
bodies are feeling great, our mind works
better, too. We're able to make good
decisions. And before I forget,
this Saturday, we have a special Zoom.
Yes, AJ put his hand up and I'm like, I
can't forget this. Uh we have a special
Zoom that we're going to be broadcasting
live as I will be in Newark, New Jersey
with AJ uh doing a presentation on
nutrition and uh touching on the
benefits of the business as well, but
focusing on the power of nutrition and
what it can do within the body. So make
sure that you are tuning in. We're going
to be using the same Zoom room daily
withdoom.com.
It will be available for you to join us.
That is going to be at 3 to 6 Eastern
time. So for those of you in the Pacific
time zone, that's 12 to 3. Um Mountain
is 1 to 4, Central 2,
Eastern again 3-6.
and we invite you to to plug in and be
part of that special Zoom that's going
to be this Friday, May 4th,
that is sponsored by AJ, one of our
co-hosts. So, I am super excited to be
able to uh
travel and support my team and help them
in spreading this message. So, folks, be
part of it. Spread this message. Share
this video with somebody. Especially as
we are going through and hearing that
there are things that you can do
or someone you love can do to improve
their health journey.
U-turns are accepted, folks. We're not
going to ever stop you from making a
U-turn when it comes to your health.
Have I forgotten anything to you?
No. Okay. So, reservations, are they
required for uh New Jersey? AJ, if
you're jumping on the Zoom, no, you do
not have to have a reservation.
>> No reservations. Come as you are. Bring
a friend.
>> Especially Nancy.
>> Especially [laughter] you, Nancy. Thank
you, Nancy, for that question. Folks,
>> wait. say if you come in on Zoom, make
sure you're dressed and stay fully
dressed, please.
>> Yes, we shouldn't have to say that, but
you know, people don't realize that.
Yes, your camera is on. We see it all.
So, please have respect for yourself and
keep you covered.
Thank you for joining us here on Daily
with Doc. My name is Becca Dukes and we
look forward to hearing from you. Drop
us if you're out on the different
platforms, drop us a little note. Let us
know that you're there. And um if you
have questions, questions
dailywithdoc.com.
If you'd like more information about our
opportunity with the daily doc team,
you're not already talking to somebody,
then please go to info or send us a
message on infobwithdoc.com.
[snorts] Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to date the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may
[music] not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding health or income.
As an empowered individual, you have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of [music] the
science of epigenetics guiding us with
the best options to obtain or maintain
optimal health. Dr. Joel Wallik